so first up people see all of you all
you guys in all these videos but here's
something we've never really dealt with
what's your name and what do you do my
name is Martin Polyakov and I'm so
called research professor in chemistry
so I do chemical research and I teach my
name is Samantha tang my job title is
public awareness scientist - which
doesn't mean much to many people but in
effect my role in the school chemistry
is to communicate to the public the
research work that we do and also to
engage with the public and especially
with schoolchildren on a variety of
different projects activities events
that we run my name is Pete isince I'm a
chemist and my research work is based
upon the use of a different type of
liquid so it's a liquid which is made
only of ions and it's like no simple
neutral molecules in there at all and we
use these ionic liquids to to try and
develop new forms of catalysis new types
of materials production and chemical
reactions or processes that have a
reduced environmental footprint so my
name is Debra Ches
I am a lecturer in inorganic chemistry
at the University of Nottingham you
could say my work is thematic in green
chemistry or the words I prefer to use a
more sustainable types of chemistry so
my name is Darren mulch and I'm a
physical chemist and my research
involves looking at muck mostly involves
looking at new types of energy
conversion devices so what I mean by
that is we do a lot of work in fuel cell
catalysis we do work on super capacitors
and we also do chemistry in ionic
liquids I'm dr. Robert Stockman or Rob
to most people I'm an organic chemist I
work in the area of natural product
synthesis right my name's Steve little
I research compounds which contain
uranium and lanthanide metals because I
think they're really interesting and
there's not been enough research done
about them so I look into them and find
lots of surprises my name is John Moses
and I'm an organic chemist which well
with specializing in making natural
products molecules that exist in nature
and we try and make them in the
laboratory especially if they have a
particular function or activity safer
against bacteria or cancer or if they're
just kind of interesting structurally
interesting we'll try and make them so
we're like artists we try and sculpt
molecules using chemistry I guess there
would be a simple explanation so there
you go I'm a molecular architect if you
want to put it that way